bien
[Música]
gracias por seguir con nosotros
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy nos
acompaña aún este joven capaz director
de operaciones de vuelo de avianca
holdings para hablar sobre las medidas
de bioseguridad dentro de los aviones en
medio de la pandemia gracias señor capaz
por estar con nosotros y comienzo
preguntándole qué es lo que respiramos
en los aviones y cuál es la calidad del
aire
hola muy buenos días a todos y muchas
gracias por la invitación si
efectivamente entre los aviones
respiramos aire aire ambiente aire
totalmente purificado por los filtros de
alta eficiencia y para lo que generan
prevista en cualquier tipo de contagio
dentro de las aeronaves
bueno pero como es el mantenimiento de
este aire acondicionado se habla de
altos estándares es el mismo en el aire
o la calidad del aire dependiendo de las
horas de vuelo
bueno entendiendo tu pregunta en el aire
dentro del avión se recircula cada tres
minutos y entra aire ambiente nuevo al
avión a través de las turbinas y los
paquetes del aire acondicionado y la
presurización y estos filtros hepa los
filtran como como se los dije ahorita
con una eficiencia extremadamente alta y
esta recirculación se da a cada tres min
adicionalmente en avianca dentro del
programa de mantenimiento se cambian
estos filtros y estos paquetes de aire
dependiendo de los ciclos del aeronave o
de las horas de vuelo dentro del
programa de mantenimiento pero dentro
del avión y dentro del vuelo en crucero
cada tres minutos se barre circulando el
aire bueno señor capaz sin embargo una
de las grandes preocupaciones de la
ciudadanía ahora que empiezan a
retomarse los vuelos es subirse a un
avión y contagiarse de kobe 19 por estar
en un ambiente cerrado qué garantías
existen de no contagio
fue en realidad el contagio un avión es
prácticamente nulo prácticamente no lo
tenemos unos protocolos de bioseguridad
bastante robustos bastante robustos
dentro de la aerolínea dentro de avianca
que hemos diseñado desde el momento del
check-in hasta que el pasajero sale
nuevamente del aeropuerto al cual al
cual arriba estudios nos han demostrado
que los aviones en contagiarse es
prácticamente imposible por lo que me ha
dicho también anteriormente y él
recircula miento del aire a través de
estos filtros de alta eficiencia
entonces contagiarse en un avión es es
casi es casi imposible por no decir
imposible bueno y el otro tema es el
distanciamiento hay sillas vacías en los
aviones dispuestas para aún más bajar
este riesgo de contagio usted diría que
no es ni siquiera necesario
si en realidad no es necesario ningún
estado ha adoptado estas medidas de la
de mantener una silla vacía entre los
pasajeros entendiendo que los pasajeros
están sentados
de frente no hay no hay digamos no hay
no hay una mirada entre pasajeros
y esto genera una protección adicional
en las sillas como en las ideas del
avión como una barrera adicional entre
los pasajeros el flujo del aire el flujo
del aire va hacia de arriba
entonces no no hay ningún tipo de riesgo
con respecto al contrario en ese sentido
y adicionalmente las los filtros hepa
también como se lo mencioné
anteriormente se filtra en cualquier
tipo de gota en el ambiente recuerden
también que los pasajeros deben portar
su tapabocas de forma permanente dentro
del avión entonces adoptar este tipo de
medidas no genera ningún ninguna
garantía adicional para evitar contagio
dentro de los aviones por por tal motivo
la silla vacía no se está adoptando en
ninguna en ninguna operación dentro de
los países conocidos
bueno y usted no se está hablando de
unas cadenas de protocolos que empiezan
desde que la persona llega al aeropuerto
incluso desde que desde que compra su
tiquete en qué consiste en estas medidas
que aseguran que no se suba a un avión
una persona que podría estar contagiada
digamos que empecemos por el recorrido
en el aeropuerto al aeropuerto no pueden
ingresar sino los pasajeros que
efectivamente van a volar estamos
incrementando o adoptando medidas
adicionales para que los pasajeros no
tengan ni siquiera que ir a nuestros
puntos de check-in sino que puedan hacer
los check in desde los medios magnéticos
que tenemos implementado en avianca para
tal fin en el caso en el caso tal que un
pasajero necesite llegar al check-in
porque no pudo imprimir su su pas a
bordo porque no lo tiene a la mano
porque tiene que llevar una maleta por
bodega etcétera
tenemos unos protocolos muy bien
establecidos donde tenemos unos 12
unos vidrios de acrílico acrílico para
que no haya contacto entre el pasajero y
el personal de check-in luego pues todos
los filtros que se realicen en el
aeropuerto y llegando ya al avión como
les digo donde nuestros tripulantes de
cabina tienen tapabocas caretas guantes
trajes a las medidas y nos explica
además de filtro del aire señor capaz
disculpe que el 20 rompa pero llegamos
ya al final de nuestro tiempo al aire
gracias a usted por estar con nosotros
en nuestros televidentes continúen en
buenas 24 muchas gracias
[Música]